[Music]
he
was the every frog the amphibian that
felt all the things we felt we cockers
there yeah one of the other ones going
pepe the frog became one of the most
popular memes
in the world and perhaps nowhere did he
become as
indispensable as on twitch as he grew in
popularity
so too did his variations and the
breadth of emotions
he could help communicate we use like an
image to capture our feelings
that's like let's literally like because
we don't understand like we can
we use the pepe but while twitch was
keeping it hypers
to the rest of the world pepe was
getting pretty monka s
all key tenants making up the emerging
racist
ideology known as the alt right
this pepe the frog thing one of the
things that i tweeted was some guy that
called me
you just admitted you're a nazi i posted
a meme that someone had created of me
as peppy the frog we have a talk and
they're like you can never you cannot
tweet or associate you have any emotes
you have with pepe the frog
anything you cannot associate with pepe
you have to delete all you know if you
have emotes on your twitch channel
if they delete all your tweets about
pepe and so i did that
[Music]
this is the story of the meme that went
from emotional touchstone
to alleged hate symbol and then was
revived
again and now it's back and it didn't
die
and now people are using it
appropriately i mean that's just what i
imagine when i imagine like the default
twitch viewer if you
close your eyes and imagine a twitch
beer it's just to me espibo or pepe
comes to mind i want to see some pepe
pains in the chat i want to see some
pepe pains in the chat
remember pepe the frog this is him now
feels good man
in 2005 during the golden age of web
comics
matt fury released boys club number one
and among its group of listless
post-college animal bros
the comic featured a chill frog named
pepe
pepe is like he's a really personal
character to me uh
as i created him he's one of four
characters in a comic book called boys
club
and uh you know he's just like a stone
frog dude that likes to
hang out eat snacks and like fart with
his buddies
and between fat bong rips and crushing
sodas
he'd like to pee with his pants all the
way down
why you might ask feels good man while
fury's creation did find a tension in
the young internet landscape
in 2008 the meme started to pick up some
real steam on popular internet message
board
4chan it became an in-joke of sorts a
stand-in for the user's own feelings
and while feels good man had been the
frog's most iconic line in boys club
it was a remix of that feels bad man
sometimes called sad frog
that became the predominant version on
4chan
a growing mix of social media networks
image sites and gaming communities
started to embrace pepe as online games
and streaming
continued to explode in popularity then
in 2014 pepe escaped into the cultural
mainstream posts by celebrities like
katy perry and nicki minaj
exposed even more people to pepe whether
he felt
good bad or whatever this was
gaming and particularly streaming
adopted pepe
in a big way pepes were essentially a
way to react to things
and in the streaming world that's a big
part of what viewers did
they reacted to whatever was on-screen
for as long as we've had media there's
been fandom
cheering and clapping at the end of
films songs like take me out to the ball
game
react emojis on your iphone and for
twitch
pepe filled that void on a platform
filled with highs and lows
crying screaming molding sweating and
everything in between
one frog's face became a vessel for
participation
and we all fell in love with him the
advent of the better twitch tv
and frankerface's add-ons in the 2010s
allowed users to add their own emails
and pepe emotes became incredibly
popular
due to their emotional range the pepe
hands better twitch tv emote and monka s
franker faces emote were popularized by
forsen's community
[Music]
hypers came up through greek god x's
community
before generally becoming a kind of pepe
pog champ
a way to let pepe express your
excitement
we cockers there we go there we go
one the other one's going because the
other one's turn and monka s
in particular clearly an expression of
anxiety or nervousness
was a perfect fit on twitch where the
audience often washed with baited breath
as their favorite streamer strolled into
the unknown
on twitch pepe basically stayed in that
pre-2014 state
but it wasn't like that everywhere in
2018
the overwatch league explicitly told
players
not to post about the cartoon frog on
social media
they also timed out users for using pepe
related emotes from their overwatch
starcraft and heroes of the storm
channels including those from content
creators
that played their games the band came to
light after a tweet by then
overwatch league player jay sinatra wong
esports community member rod slasher
breslau then revealed that blizzard had
previously banned
fan signs with pepe and asked players to
remove
tweets about the frog and according to
former overwatch league player ted
silkthread wang he had been told as
early as march of 2018 that any
association with pepe
would not be tolerated by the league i
was my twitter game was weak
still is weak but it was weaker back
then and i needed content to tweet so i
was thinking of something to tweet for
really long and i eventually was like oh
i'll tweet
does anyone else love pepe the frog
question mark
that's the entirety of my tweet okay two
hours after i tweet that my social media
manager on valiant tells me to delete it
instantly
and then i'm like okay i i don't know
why but i did it
and then oh my god and then like
later like the next day or something we
have a talk and they're like you can
never you cannot tweet or associate
any emotes you have with pepe the frog
anything you cannot associate with pepe
you have to delete all you know if you
have emotes under your twitch channel
delete all your tweets about pepe and so
i did that
to understand why we have to go back to
2015.
[Music]
pepe had largely gone mainstream and was
used by people that 4chain labeled
normies the kind of people applauding as
katy perry and nicki minaj posted pepes
there had been some association with
darker communities like the 4chan
r9k board and their celebration of incel
inspired violence
but pepe was still largely seen as a
wholesome reaction meme by the general
public but there were some people on
4chan and elsewhere
who wanted that to end and the only way
to get the public to turn their back on
pepe
was to turn pepe into something the
public couldn't accept
a now suspended twitter user told the
daily beast
that associating pepe with white
nationalist ideology
had been an intentional goal and though
later accounts would say that the
website had been
trolled the article was picked up by
hillary clinton's presidential campaign
as part of their claim that pepe had
become affiliated
with white supremacy that happened
because pepe had also started to become
affiliated
with donald j trump's presidential
campaign after he tweeted a picture of
the frog in october 2015
sporting his signature hairstyle and
while some supporters began to embrace
the pepe meme as part of a pro-trump
outlook
others went darker adding trappings of
nazism or anti-semitism to images of
pepe
whether the users quoted in the daily
beast article or
twitter users adding frog emojis to
their handles were really just
trying to troll the media or not by the
time of donald trump's inauguration
there were real self-avowed white
supremacists like richard b
spencer who wore pepe with pride
it's pepe has become kind of assembly it
all
culminated in the addition of pepe the
frog
to the anti-defamation league's hate
symbols database
in fall 2016. meet pepe the frog
he's the latest symbol to be added to
the anti-defamation league's
hate symbols database yes pepe
who has also come to be known as sad
frog joins the ranks of the swastika
and 14 words but even the adl's page on
pepe said that the vast majority of
users were not
posting racist or anti-semitic pepes
and that context was everything so while
many
understandably turned away from pepe
after the adl's declaration
pepe was more heavily ingrained in some
communities
than others at the same time pepe
creator matt fury was trying to regain
control of his creation
one that had clearly heavily diverged
from his initial incarnation
in 2017 he wrote a comic depicting the
death of pepe
an attempt to bury both the old frog and
the new but he also launched
lawsuits against companies selling
products depicting pepe
including infowars and nazi website the
daily stormer
and an emoticon on steam that featured
pepe was
caught up in that campaign while the
mild-mannered fury was doing his best to
put the genie back in the bottle
the greater internet was debating what
to do with pepe
facebook came up with an official policy
on pepe
he wasn't unilaterally banned but if
used in hateful contexts
it would be addressed for most pepe was
still just a funny frog meme
but that takes us back to the overwatch
league the adl's decision
led to their choice to ban pepe
overwatch league is an esport
and for many viewers twitch is
synonymous with that experience
so there was significant backlash
against the move
even among the league's staff although
they couldn't say so publicly at the
time
but twitch is clearly bigger than just
blizzard esports
and so pepe continued to exist new
streamers came up and
with them came more pepes in many ways
it's been the world of twitch and gaming
that have brought everyone's favorite
frog
back from its stint on the razor's edge
of cultural uncertainty
over the course of the last few years
pepe has mostly returned to the fun
emotional frog that we fell in love with
from the beginning emotes like poggers
feels weird man wide people sad and sad
continued to help twitch users express
their feelings about whatever happened
on the streaming platform and in many
cases these memes became
larger than life i want to see some pepe
pains in the chat i want to see some
pepe pains in the chat
over the course of the last 365 xqc
is by far the most watched streamer on
twitch
and pepe might as well be his own
personal mascot
oh no give me a kick w uh i can't
stop it by late 2018
it was pretty common to see even some of
the biggest streamers on twitch
not just edgy boys like forsen doing
some pepe posting
why am i like this maybe twitch
would have ended up as pepe's retirement
home a community of dank gamers swapping
jokes
iterating on the frog meme and just
having a good time
oh let's name it
good boy but he made a big move
to the unlikeliest of places hong kong
the 2019-2020 protests in hong kong
initially centered around a proposed
extradition law but as the campaign took
to the streets to protest perceived
judicial overreach by china
pepe the frog was weirdly at the
vanguard
and the message had nothing to do with
its alleged association
to the alt-right we may never know the
precise moment that pepe appeared in
hong kong or
the exact reasons but as the
international center on non-violent
conflict pointed out
pepe is easy to draw which helps with
putting up graffiti
but also his most popular incarnation is
the sad frog
a dissatisfied amphibian that isn't
afraid to make his feelings known
even so questions remain about pepe's
future
in 2018 fury wrote another comic
one that brought the frog back from the
dead has pepe truly remained
safe for all to use there are some who
continue to ban him from their channels
or
platforms and obviously that's their
choice
but on twitch in 2021 the frog has
mostly kept the original spirit
intact and perhaps no example hits home
harder
than the people animations made by aw
[Music]
i guess i mean that's just what i
imagine when i imagine like the default
twitch
viewer i just because because the emotes
get used so much it's just it seems like
if you just close your eyes and imagine
a twitch fear it just to me
a people or pepe comes to mind i guess
depending which age demographic you're
imagining
harnessing the pathos of a fan streamer
relationship
gone wrong pipo a poorly drawn version
of pepe
stands in for the every fan and though
the storyline
is constructed it still made a big
impact on twitch this is such a
masterpiece
seriously this is whoever this person is
they're a gift to this community i would
die for this
five i would too like a few people cried
which
i don't know what to make of that
because it's mo it's all supposed to be
in humor
two or three i remember two or three
videos of people like crying and stuff
um so those ones are are come to mind
and also tyler1
his reaction was the most i guess
unexpected to me because like
i'd expect him well he kind of does like
go with his persona i guess
i would never treat you guys like this
ever
oh you got a vet and honestly that's
where pepe
is today there will always be people who
will use any widely recognized symbol
for ill whether they claim they're
joking or
not but the truth is that twitch and the
internet
have reclaimed pepe just like pepe
was originally like unassuming and then
turned into something
mean but then was reappropriated both by
reappropriated both by the the creator
itself
but then also by people on twitch and
while he will remain
banned in some places in others he
continues to help do
what he always did express the feelings
that seemed so
difficult in text alone
[Music]
feels good man
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages